and what can only be described as a wao
moment The Matrix catapulted keano
Reeves from a well-known Hollywood actor
to a global Superstar and he hasn't been
the same ever since the Matrix was far
from Reeves's first significant movie
role the actor was already well
established and had appeared in a number
of hit films from speed alongside Sandra
bulock to the comedy time traveling
series Bill and Ted however the sheer
popularity of the wowski Cyber Punk
spectacle and its widespread success
catapulted Reeves and many other cast
members to a new level of super stard
them Reeves went from being a fairly
recognizable actor to a hugely beloved
star almost overnight it provided him
with a more serious image and led to
audiences seeing him in a different
light than before in an interview with
Esquire the actor revealed his gratitude
to Will Smith for turning down the role
of Neo in the first place and detailed
some of the impact the movie had on him
he said well it changed my life and it
was such a wonderful creative experience
and so to play Neo in The Matrix trilogy
and now in the fourth it impacted my
life personally and creatively the
release of the Matrix may have been a
watershed moment in Kian Reza's career
but the movie also marked a more tragic
turn in his personal life just a few
months after the film was released his
longtime girlfriend Jennifer Sim gave
birth to a stillborn daughter named Ava
the grief ultimately led to Reeves and
Sim ending their relationship shortly
afterward with the loss of their child
causing a tremendous The Strain between
them despite this they remained close
and were on friendly terms they later
reconciled and once again started dating
in 2001 s died after she crashed her car
while returning to a party hosted by
shock rocker Marilyn Manson according to
police reports she lost control of her
vehicle and made contact with several
parked cars which caused Sim to reject
from the car at high speed Reeves has
rarely spoken about his personal life
but opened up to the guardian saying
grief and L those are things that don't
ever go away they stay with you the
Matrix ensured kiano ree's life will be
forever changed simply because of the
amount of money that he earned from the
role he became one of the highest paid
actors of all time receiving somewhere
in the region a $15 million per film but
what really made the series of Payday
for Reeves is that he received a cut of
the gross earnings for the original
trilogy considering that the first few
films are all huge financial money
makers and brought in more than 1.6 B
million dollars total the actor was
certainly able to cash in as well
throwing his performance in The Matrix
resurrections and Reeves is reported to
have been paid a total of $150 million
for portraying Neo on screen that puts
the role among the most expensive in
movie history and UND doubtedly can be
considered life-changing money for any
individual wow that sounds like a really
good deal although keano Reeves came to
the Public's attention as a result of
his breakthrough role in Bill and Ted's
Excellent Adventure in 1989 the actor
was perhaps best known as an action star
he had leading Parts in Point Break and
speed in the early 1990s portraying Law
Enforcement Officers attempting to stop
criminals from carrying out dly plans
but it was his performance in The Matrix
that truly established Reeves as a
bankable and leading Action Hero after
starring as Neo in the first three
Matrix films he took on the leading role
in the 2013 fantasy action movie 47
Ronin and also starred in Man of Tai Chi
in the same year co-starring with tiger
Chen most famously though the actor is
famous for portraying John Wick in the
franchise of the same name Reeves has
played the fan favorite assassin with a
soft spot for dogs across four movies
and the property is expanded to include
a spin-off TV show and feature film The
Matrix received a lot of Praise when it
hit theaters in 1999 and chief among the
Acclaim was a high octane and stylized
fight scenes getting in shape to be able
to take part in the stunts and make the
action look believable was tough the
actors had to go through an intensive
training race regime under the
instruction of famed choreographer
Master Yen Wu ping it was a process that
lasted several months outside of
preparing re for his work on The Matrix
this training seemingly instilled a
desire to maintain his Fitness and stay
active his personal trainer Patrick
Murphy has explained that the actor
spends a large amount of time in the gym
working on his core strength and
endurance to give him the ability to do
much of the stunt work in the John Wick
franchise himself this allows Reeves to
recover quickly and remain balanced
during strength continuous exercise
speaking to GQ Murphy said keano is
second to numb when it comes to focus
and effort for a physical role following
the Triumph of the Matrix Kian Reeves
has been able to take some chances in
his career this has even led to him
occasionally becoming involved with the
projects where he works behind the
camera instead of in front of it most
notably he directed The multilingual
martial arts film man of taichi in
addition to portraying one of the
leading characters the film received
praise from critics but failed to be a
financial success ESS that hasn't
deterred Reeves though as he has
expressed interest in directing again in
2012 he produced and narrated the
documentary side by side which looks
into the changes in modern film making
and features interviews with David Lynch
Christopher Nolan and Martin scori
additionally Reeves has been heavily
involved in the making of the F1
documentary Brawn The Impossible Formula
1 story for Disney plus and acts as host
and narrator he is also involved in the
adaptation of his comic book series
Berserker produced by Netflix
excellent the tragic death of Kiana
Reeves former girlfriend Jennifer Sim in
2001 understandably made romantic
relationships more difficult for him
according to multiple sources the ACT
LGE he remained single after Sim's death
and divided discussing his personal life
this was likely a result of ree's grief
and his attempts to come to terms with
what had happened however the actor has
confirmed he is in a relationship with
artist Alexandra Grant the pair
originally met years ago and have worked
on several books together but only
revealed they were dating in 2019 it
hasn't been made public how long they've
been dating for but friends of the
couple suggest they may have been
together longer than most people realize
despite being somewhat reclusive about
his private life the actor has spoken
publicly about Grant in an interview
with people he was asked about when he
last experienced Bliss he said a couple
of days ago with my honey we were in bed
we were connected he were smiling and
laughing and giggling feeling great it
was just really nice to be together
Reeves became an internet meme in 2010
when a photograph emerged of him sitting
alone on a bench eating a sandwich the
suen and Moody look gave rise to what
people called sad keano with the image
soon going viral fans quickly
established June 15th as an an official
International holiday called cheer up
keano day despite all the online buz
Reeves was initially unaware of the
extent of the meme until it was made
made clear to him in an interview with
vulture a few months later with fans
around the world discussing what was
going on in his head to make him look so
unhappy Rees Finally Revealed the answer
in an interview on The Late Show with
Steven colar according to the actor
nothing particularly upsetting prompted
the photograph rather it was a
combination of several rather mundane
factors and he was really just eating a
sandwich I was thinking I had some stuff
going on sure I was hungry being a
celebrity might seem like the best thing
in the world and it certainly comes with
plenty of perks however there is also a
dark side to being a public figure and
it can sometimes attract individuals who
want to get a little too close for
comfort one far too common issue comes
with stalkers who become obsessive over
famous people and go to extreme lens to
see them this is something that has
affected kanano Reeves during his career
The Hollywood Reporter revealed in early
2023 that the actor secured a temporary
restraining order in Los Angeles against
an alleged stalker according to court
arguments the 38-year-old man reportedly
turned up at ree's home and harassed him
multiple times police investigations
confirm the person that trespassed at
the actor's house in Los Angeles at
least six times at one point leaving
behind the DNA kit that he intended to
use to try and prove he and Reeves are
related in 2022 Kean Reeves recited the
poem Paul my daisy as part of the 35th
annual House of tobet benefit concert
the event is closely associated with the
Dalai llama and is contentious within
China due to its support for tibet's
Independence Movement almost immediately
after his appearance was announced
Chinese nationalists spoke out against
the actor and even proposed boycotts of
movies starring reefs including the
Matrix resurrections many of those who
are previously voice support for Tibet
have seen censorship in China with
performers effectively having any
content featuring them banned as a
result a similar fate awaited re with
Chinese authorities forcing streaming
sites within the country to remove his
film films platforms such as 10 cents
removed all mention of reefs with films
like the Matrix and The Lakehouse all
being pulled from streaming services
considering the importance of China as a
growing market for Cinema this may have
a significant effect on Reeves's career
moving forward W 2022 sawano Reeves
named as one of the most influential
people of the Year by Time Magazine he
was listed alongside actors such as
Andrew Garfield Zoe Kravitz and munes as
well as figures such as Ukraine
president lomia zalinski and Apple CEO
Tim Cook the annual list was first
published in 1999 and features
individuals that time writers and
contributors feel have had the most
influence and power over events in the
world re's friend a matrix co-star carry
a mro's entry in time stating his
Essence and Humanity come through every
character he plays as well as in the
everyday interactions that the world
catches glimpses of we don't need to be
inspired by something bigger than us but
rather by what already lives inside of
us keano so kindly illuminates this for
us all in the early 2000s Reeves made
forbes's annual celebrity 100 list and
receiv received a star in the Hollywood
Walk of Fame meanwhile the New York
Times called him the fourth best actor
of the 21st century outside of the world
of acting and film Kiana Reeves has
continued his artistic efforts he
created the comic series Berserker
serving as writer for the 12 issue
limited series his other publishing
projects include o to happiness and
shadows a collaborative project
illustrated by his partner Alexandra
Grant alongside Grant and Jessica fman
Reeves set up ex artist books as an
independent publishing house for
Creative books his movie success and
wealth gives Reeves the ability to
pursue another passion motorcycles with
guard haringer he sets up his own custom
motorcycle company in the form of arch
Motorcycle company and released custom
bikes such as the KR GT1 for
$78,000 the actor is also well known for
his work with the alternative rock band
dog
he founded the group with Robert
mailhouse and the pair currently
performs with Brett domrose who replaced
Greg Miller they released two albums
before going on Hiatus in 2002 but
reformed to go on tour and put out the
third album in
[Music]